hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to troll face quest 3 now
you guys seem to enjoy these types of
games and I want to be hip and cool with
the kids with all your yoloz and whatnot
so I want to play this game and bash my
head against wall over and over
oh no that whatever is what is always a
sock okay I thought his head was just
slightly misshapen my apologies oh no
the troll ELISA has been stolen this guy
seems rather upset about it well what
are you gonna do oh hey well okay what
why was there a bomb landing in the
middle of a road okay it's so am I
supposed to do about that okay so that's
all right
at least the arts better in this game
but unfortunately I seem to be nope that
ain't gonna work okay goddamnit I
thought it'd be stuck here forever
oh I start and stop it oh well okay I
guess I wasn't supposed to hit the
landmine wait what wait oh haha okay I
got it I got it I made it
click me okay [ __ ] well I mean what was
I supposed to do I follow directions I'm
a follower okay so am I not supposed to
click what else could I possibly do what
do you want from me game I'm gonna do it
I broke a deal I see okay so yeah [ __ ]
goddamnit
I thought those onto something there all
right oh hey cool I did it by wanting to
seek other hey pretty lady
you look like cry but with boobies would
you like my Apple oh sorry that's not
what I meant to do
oh I see daddy how about now would you
like that who you wanted me to eat the
apple are you so kind or something I
don't know okay
ha ha oh it's one of the opposite things
ha ha that was this a skill game that
wasn't anything actually difficult her
I'm an army man I wanna whoop ok I guess
I'm getting good at this game blue
bloods love ah he died it's just like
the drowning simulator game except is
for real in real life okay so oh yay I
found this hidden bathroom drain the
ocean I've killed every sea creature
ever to exist and everyone's happier for
it die Oh
am well alright then nope
he just seems to be dying over and over
again okay so stand up oh okay Isaac
Newton in this [ __ ]
yeah I've got a penis on my head now
okay am I supposed to move the tree no
cuz apparently as allow things need to
be moved in this game because it's just
stupid and I hate it oh oh oh
why didn't know I was supposed to kill
the guy why was that an objective
oh that's somnus and terrifying
all right then okay this doesn't seem
very complicated series of okay not
understanding what you're wanting from
me called roll call
literally t r o ll is that my grandma oh
okay [ __ ] literally okay what up
is that I see a little dot there is that
just as my come here is my computer
monitor dirty or is that X anything no
it doesn't seem to work okay so they've
gotta be like hey I found him little
itty bitty thing okay poison how about
poison oh that didn't work how about not
poisoned how about poison oh maybe I'm
not protecting poison because maybe I'm
just an idiot here okay 103 uh-uh
okay shut up hi it seems to be a lot of
really creepy nature going on here me
okay so what else am I supposed to do
about you mr. tree man him me okay
when I just start him up like a
lawnmower and then off he goes that
doesn't make any sense
oh hey how are you are you or how how
are you okay oh you need okay bye
I thought I needed you
I have no idea what's going on here and
I don't know if it's euphemism for
something that I shouldn't be looking at
or what hey ah there we go
okay I just need to hold him down like
one of the other things I gotta remember
from the other games because there were
other rules and I okay by the head what
the hell
no comeback there's only land mines in
the water water mines whatever you call
them I don't know oh oh that would be
okay I get you can't hold that one down
okay no well I saw something good
hey is it gonna spell my name here great
oh no oh I thought I was gonna be
important huh mob bum my bum
I'm dumb I'm not dumb I'm smart yes yes
under you Wow okay cool okay I don't
know what that's all about
alright so there's got to be something
that I need what do I do now not that no
can't be all right then
apparel oh I was imitating the crab when
I was running oh listen
this is the post-apocalyptic scenario
okay this seems like a fruitless task
this is gonna end with me losing isn't
it you son of a [ __ ] five god damnit no
I don't want to play your game you rogue
what did I do
wait what did I do no hang on I don't
know why I did
oh I push oh oh okay that makes more
sense I got you okay
I'll easily spot five differences well I
would if you would move your freaking
hands okay and the easy way to do these
is to cross your eyes and then you can
tell the differences because the
difference is literally glow when
they're overlapped with each other and
I'm not seeing a fifth one
Oh oh no no those are it was an ad on
the side I thought itself something like
it was really weird for a second there
okay there's got to be like it's gonna
be like a tiny tiny thing I'm not seeing
anything I don't know I don't know I
don't know what do you want from me I
don't know I don't know I'm a stupid
little boy who doesn't know anything
cool all right I'm like I'm like
crossing my eyes trying to see if
there's any little thing that's a
difference here but apparently it's not
because I'm really really dry I'm
thinking that it's not her it's like the
background but I've just been spamming
my clicker clicker maybe it's on the
frame or something maybe it's someone
like there's nothing like usually this
trick works if you cross your eyes
anything that's different will glow and
there's gonna be nothing that can pop
oh oh oh Venus the troller
oh no boobs blur that out son of a [ __ ]
this son of a [ __ ] [ __ ] you you know
what - screw you I hate you god damn
that was [ __ ] it wasn't even like a
thing that was different I didn't even
know I was supposed to be looking for
something that I could click on what a
piece of [ __ ] hey the way that's
trollface quest number three apparently
there's a number four and a five and
then another type of game that I looked
up made by the same grader Zoe the way
if you want to see those my way tell in
the comments below thank you everybody
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video oh that's
disgusting why was that a thing that
happened